[Música]
los candidatos a la presidencia de
Brasil se encontraron en su último
debate el presidente Yahir bolsonaro y
su rival el ex mandatario Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva se midieron nuevamente en
un cara a cara antes de la segunda
vuelta de este domingo
los estadounidenses también se preparan
para ir a las urnas a un poco más de una
semana de las elecciones de medio
término dos temas están moviendo a los
votantes por un lado datos
inflacionarios históricos y por otro la
eliminación del derecho constitucional
al aborto
la ONU advierte sobre la inversión de
gas natural en América Latina y el
Caribe según el organismo este
hidrocarburo retrasa la implementación
de energías renovables y agrava la
crisis climática estoy en medio de una
crisis energética derivada de la guerra
en Ucrania
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil los candidatos a la presidencia
de ese país se vieron cara a cara por
última vez antes de la segunda vuelta de
este domingo 30 de octubre el debate
como en ocasiones anteriores estuvo
marcado por ataques entre el presidente
Jair bolsonaro y el ex mandatario Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva los detalles nos
los entregaba previamente nuestra
corresponsal en Río de Janeiro Valeria
saconi
hay prácticamente unanimidad entre los
analistas políticos y los periodistas
brasileños que han comentado en las
redes sociales el último debate entre
Jair bolsonaro y Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva Lula sería el ganador ha tenido un
buen desempeño en todos los bloques del
debate se ha mostrado seguro de sí
atacado y mucho a bolsonado pero casi
siempre con argumentos intentando o bien
mostrar
incongruencias en su gestión o delatar
su falta de conocimiento por ejemplo en
temas económicos hemos visto bolsonaro
bastante nervioso levantando la voz en
más de una ocasión ha habido momento que
casi ha perdido el equilibrio sea
tambaleado pero hay que decir que
bolsonaro ha mejorado con respecto a los
primeros debates y en general con
respecto a toda su trayectoria política
se nota que ambos han pasado por un duro
entrenamiento ha habido En todo caso el
típico cruce de acusaciones
cada uno de los candidatos ha tildado al
otro de ser mentiroso habido momentos
tensos pero también se ha hablado de
varios asuntos como la salud el aborto
la creación de empleo o el medio
ambiente y la preservación de la
amazonia en más de una ocasión Lula ha
intentado hablar del futuro y traer el
debate a los programas de gobierno para
salirse de esta dinámica de
descalificaciones que parece haberse
convertido en la tónica general de los
debates de esta campaña electoral que
está llegando a su fin ya no queda más
margen para convencer a los indecisos el
domingo sabremos Quién es el próximo
presidente de Brasil cambiamos de tema
Hablamos ahora de las elecciones de
medio término de Estados Unidos que se
celebrarán el próximo 8 de noviembre
demócratas y republicanos resaltan sus
diferencias ideológicas temas como la
defensa del derecho al aborto podrían
ser clave en esta votación por la
indignación que generó la decisión del
tribunal supremo de revocar la
interrupción del embarazo como un
derecho Federal pero con la inflación
más alta registrada en cuatro décadas el
contexto económico es otro asunto que
preocupa a los electores lee nos amplía
una candidata dando a luz
apoyando el derecho de la mujer a
decidir sobre su cuerpo en su anuncio de
campaña es uno de los numerosos ejemplos
mostrando el papel que tomó el aborto en
la política estadounidense;
para los demócratas pronunciarse sobre
este tema tiene un objetivo claro
recordará sus votantes un derecho
perdido que está en juego en las
elecciones de medio término y ganar
votos en el campo adversario
los demócratas esperan que haya un grupo
suficientemente grande de mujeres de
tendencia republicana y se centran
especialmente en las mujeres blancas con
estudios universitarios cuya política
ideológica no están extrema como la de
otro republicanos que se preocupan por
las cuestiones relacionadas con el
aborto y votarían a los demócratas por
lo que perciben como libertad
reproductiva pero en Estados Unidos la
inflación Ya borró las preocupaciones
por los derechos humanos de ciertos
votantes por eso Muchos candidatos
republicanos hicieron del aumento del
costo el centro de sus campañas echando
la culpa a la administración demócrata
de raiden un argumentó que comencé en
Estados como Ohio entre el noreste
industrial y el medio oeste agrícola
cuando más dinero se gaste mayor será la
inflación ahora mismo se ve que en el
lado de los demócratas creen que gastar
más dinero va a bajar la inflación lo
cual es completamente ya sabes va en
contra del sentido común de lo que nos
han enseñado desde que éramos niños
en un reciente estudio más del 90% de
los republicanos citan la economía como
la razón más importante para votar
tras completar la adquisición de Twitter
por 44 mil millones de dólares el
multimillonario y lo más que recibió
respaldos mundiales Aunque Europa lanzó
algunas advertencias acerca del manejo
de la red social y la libertad de
expresión que dicen deben estar a corte
a las leyes del bloque Andrés granadillo
tiene los detalles
una avalancha de reacciones ocasionó el
cierre de la adquisición de Twitter por
parte de elon musk El multimillonario
dijo que restauraría la libertad de
expresión en la red social y el
vicepresidente del Consejo de Seguridad
de Rusia
dimitriever fue uno de los primeros en
reaccionar buena suerte de los muski en
la superación del sesgo político y la
dictadura ideológica en Twitter y deja
ese asunto de starlink en Ucrania la
comisión europea por su parte dijo que
Twitter tendrá que acatar las normas del
bloque esto en respuesta al tweet de
Mask que decía que el pájaro se libera
en referencia al logo de la plataforma
en Europa el pájaro volará según
nuestras reglas
bretón con toda la razón era simplemente
recordar Cuál es el marco que debe
cumplir cualquier empresa que opere en
Europa hay ciertas actividades que no se
ajustan a las normas reglamentos y leyes
de los estados miembros en particular
como usted muy bien señala cosas
relacionadas con la incitación al odio
con actividades delictivas con el
terrorismo etcétera etcétera
el ex presidente Donald Trump que fue
bloqueado por la red social dijo estar
contento ya que Twitter ya no será
dirigido por lunáticos de la izquierda
radical más que no ha ofrecido detalles
sobre cómo luchará contra la censura en
línea mientras protege a los anunciantes
de información sobre quién dirigirá a la
empresa Aunque dijo que nombrará un
consejo de moderación de contenidos con
puntos de vista diversos el empresario
que dirige la compañía de vehículos
eléctricos tesla y la empresa de cohetes
spacex planea convertirse en el
consejero delegado interino de Twitter
un nuevo informe del programa para el
medio ambiente de Naciones Unidas
cuestiona la inversión en gas natural en
países de América Latina y el Caribe
además de contaminar en mayor medida
aseguran que es menos rentable
económicamente esto en plena crisis del
mercado energético y con los países
buscando alternativas a corto plazo
lluis Muñoz tiene más detalles
los beneficios de las inversiones En gas
natural cuestionados el programa para el
medio ambiente de la ONU emitió un
informe dirigido a los países de América
Latina y el Caribe este advierte de que
invertir en gas natural retrasa
implementar renovables agrava la crisis
climática y puede convertirse en un
activo varado estos avisos se producen
después de que el organismo haya visto
que en países como Argentina Panamá y
Granada el uso del gas natural aumentó
desde la patronal regional energética lo
justifican cuando hablamos de las
disrupción que ocurren en Ucrania se
pone énfasis a la seguridad energética y
mucha gente pensó que la transición
energética se dejaba de lado pero como
dije no es una dicotomía lo que ha
pasado con la con este crisis que
tenemos en este momento es que se cambia
el ritmo pero no el rumbo del transición
energético Pero según el informe de la
ONU los beneficios económicos de la
sobre el gas natural son tres veces
superiores mientras que los puestos de
trabajo para 2050 serían 85 veces
mayores y la reducción de emisiones es
cuatro veces superior en el sector
eléctrico que en el gas natural Gustavo
umañez subdirector del programa para el
medio ambiente de América Latina y el
Caribe de la ONU pidió en Francia 24
continuar con los esfuerzos y ahí vemos
Que a ese largo plazo sí que tienes una
reducción sustancial lo que pasa es que
esto va a depender de que todas estas
políticas inversiones y compromisos se
pongan en práctica que los países
verdaderamente no den Un paso atrás
Después de la pandemia y la guerra en
Ucrania los mercados energéticos se han
visto perturbados agravándose la triple
crisis de cambio climático contaminación
y pérdida de biodiversidad desde la ONU
consideran imprudente tomar decisiones
energéticas con una visión a corto plazo
cerramos en México coloridas y
importantes catrinas Se tomaron el
Zócalo en la capital del país se trata
de una exposición con figuras de un
promedio de 7 metros de altura y que
representan a los 31 estados de la
república su presentación se da en
vísperas de la tradicional celebración
del Día de los Muertos una creencia
Azteca prehispánica que cree que los
difuntos regresan a la tierra un día
cada año para visitar a sus seres
queridos
hasta aquí este Informativo en francés
24 Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]